I hear that not too long ago you and
Andy hung out but I didn't get the call
that's so funny because Andy had said
hey let's call who else should we get
nice I said and I don't want to get any
into trouble I said let's get the guy
that you do the thing with and and you
said he died I said he was dead to me
with really dead I am all true no I did
you know guys hung out which and I'm
just curious did you have a good time we
did we did we went out for dinner we had
a fun time and we have done it the three
of us as well we've had a fun time but
Andy and I went out with our with our
friend Pete sweet Pete Giles and and
then we ran into two Will Ferrell - yes
and I actually which was a pretty funny
thing as will is coming from a school
function and we ran into him with a
bunch of other people and I brought a
photo don't play it yeah that's what the
funny yet so we'll is there with a bunch
of other parents from the school and
stuff and you know he's just being a
regular guy and you know when you go to
those things you got to meet a lot of
parents you know the kids but not all
the parents know each other and so it's
important to do this sometimes yeah so
he had he he had a name tag on Will
Ferrell nobody knew in case you haven't
been on this planet for the last 20
years I like that he kept it on yeah I
think you love probably still has an
obvious
he's pretty good he's like I can't
believe you [ __ ] show that picture
let me worry about him that's so dark
I'm a big player in the truth I'll take
care of him you killed so many people
with Joe biz oh yeah
cross Conan I come across as a real good
boy yeah but cross me and it's over you
know it's just over you know that so
many careers now your movie Megan Fox's
in the movies doesn't the first minute
in the second one and she's pregnant
yeah if I was pregnant and she revealed
which I found odd she revealed that you
are not the father
oh my god yes
[Applause]
oh that's a reaction of a dude you know
I mean when like you're not that you
don't ever get it but most you know what
I mean if you were to actually engage in
sexual relations with a woman hey guy
oh whoa like you know his life its take
my word for it on this one yeah they're
sticking up
it's completely fertile yeah so I love
your dance you haven't had a dance ever
I'm not the father which is it was a
really bad moonwalk my mic fell off but
I'm usually pretty good at moonwalking I
got to say wait
thanks man you know what I'm most
worried about these days is getting gift
you know yeah I mean because anytime you
do anything people gonna turn it when I
walked out here I was doing this this is
now a gift right yeah this right you
think do that again - Andy you think
that's gonna be a gift yeah that's a
good
you know definitely difficult now yeah
this doesn't need to be a gift get it
long enough you don't even have to loop
it yeah just throw it and it's an
original hour and 40 minutes
you